all right we'll get started good
afternoon and welcome to today's Richard
M karp distinguished lecture I'm Sandy
Ron I'm the associate director of the
Simons Institute and for those of you
who are unfamiliar with the Institute we
are the um leading international venue
for collaborative research and
theoretical computer science established
with a very generous Grant from the
Simons Foundation um The Institute
brings together researchers from all
over the world and theoretical computer
science and related fields um we
established this particular lecture
series The Richard M karp distinguished
lecture series to celebrate the role of
Simon's founding director dick karp in
establishing the field of theoretical
computer science outlining its
foundational problems and contrib
contributing a stunning array of results
um this lecture series features
Visionary leaders in the field and is
geared towards a broad scientific
audience so we're very grateful to the
people who have contributed to make this
this series possible and today I'm very
happy to welcome Val tannan who's been
here the for throughout the semester um
uh Val a professor of computer science
and information at upen and um has been
one of the organizers of the logic and
algorithms program in theory in database
Theory and Ai and indeed his research
interests aligned perfectly with the
program as he's had a deep um interest
in the intersection and connection
between logic and computer science
throughout his career initially in
programming languages and more recently
in database Theory um he's worked on
query language design
optimization more recently models and
systems for data sharing data Providence
managing uncertain information this work
has won numerous Awards um notably two
test of time Awards um the 20-year test
of time award for the International
Conference on database Theory and then
10-year ACM pods Alber Alberto Mendelson
test of time award so um his talk today
is titled is it up there it's changed
Okay you Okay well I'm gonna let B say
his own title then and please join me in
welcoming
him um thank you Sandy uh the title that
um that you advertised which I
supplied uh was not one of my better
efforts uh it was too long and almost
part of the abstract this is I think a
little more uh more
Punchy so uh I'm going to talk today
about uh things between streaming
recursion and incremental
computation now this is Joint work with
Mi buo and Leon Rik um they were at uh
VMware when they did his work they now
they now started the company in fact to
implement this work fel.com with Frank
mcer who already um started a company
called materialize
doio uh to implement a the earliest
version of some of the ideas in what I'm
going to present called differential
data flow and with t ched who has
verified our proofs and I'm happy to say
they're
correct um so Le in fact will be here on
Thursday at the industry day they will
give a talk and certainly whole lot of
questions that could be asked about what
I'm going to talk could would be better
addressed to them they certainly could
give perhaps better uh answers but let
me try to do my best with what is in
front of
you so dbsp uh DB for databases and SP
for Signal processing which is a a less
obvious connection is a platform uh in
which we um have four things that that
that's are worth noting first of all we
have synchronous streaming of
Collections and in particular of
collection
updates we have recursive computations
which are realized via synchronous
streaming which is perhaps a little
unusual and we have incrementalization
which is a word that I hate so much to
type into the slides that I'm going to
actually um just say incor but I will
spell it out so when you see this in red
it's incrementalization and also via
synchronous streaming and it all should
uh work together to provide an algebra
that supports program Transformations
and therefore optimizations as we are
used to so using so productively in
various parts of computer
science uh of all these parts I think
the one uh about incremental computation
is least familiar and it's worth while
discussing a little bit so consider a
program and the input of that program is
I and the output is O here is a picture
and now the idea is if we change the
input I let's say slightly in other
words instead of I we have I plus Delta
I uh then the output of course also
changes hopefully also slightly or at
least we are interested in those
programs in which the output changes
also
slightly and the output is o plus Delta
o and the idea is that you would like
not to recompute O because you already
did uh but just to compute this
difference this increment or decrement
whatever it is Delta o and just update o
with
it where is this useful because of
course we can you're going to give me
examples of programs in which just a
small perturbation in the input changes
completely everything they do but uh
this is useful in databases primarily
but also for example in large graph
processing or in stream processing or
various uh similar applications and the
idea is that there I and O are
collections collections of data and plus
that you have here in the picture means
update and update specifically means
deletion or
insertion uh in databases this has been
known as incremental maintenance of
materialized views the idea being that
if you have a database and you find it
useful to materialize a view of it that
is like a smaller database to make
certain queries work faster you have to
change the view when the database
changes and that's called incremental
maintenance so it's clearly uh fitting
with
that um and what I want you all to
remember from this picture and in the
next slide I will elaborate on that is
that what you would like what's
desirable is for this Delta o to
actually be
computed by some version of the query
let's call it the increment version of
the query que that takes the input and
just the change Delta
I and in a moment we'll comment why this
is
desirable now what you just saw this
picture here I replace Delta o with this
Q Delta it's called the Delta rule
that's the tradition in data basis and
using this kind of Delta rules
systematically has been a profitable way
of understanding how to apply
incremental computations in the field of
databases so let's this picture here
says this is the Delta rule for some
general query CU and the picture I just
wanted to remind you is like this why is
this interesting because you want to
take advantage that typically typically
Delta I is much much smaller than I uh
instances of databases can be ginormous
but um the updates one particular update
is relatively small and the output uh
also can be like that the the result of
the query can be pretty large but the
change can be actually much
smaller now people have in fact worked
real hard and in fact people in this
program uh present here in the room uh
to devise clever algorithms for certain
classes of queries where you can take
advantage of this to actually come up
with uh efficient ways of updating views
this
way this work is not about that but I I
need to contrast it this work is
actually how to take such contributions
that people make and integrate them in a
from a practical perspective you want to
use them in an engine that works with
complicated queries not just simple
class of
qu and I say Rich because it sounds good
rich and complex ques
so I'm going to follow these four themes
that I just stated first I'm going to
explain what are stream computations or
rather the kind of stream computations
that I consider here I'm going to talk
about recursion how it's implemented
with stream computations I'm going to
talk about incremental computation and
then uh sort of the uh culmination would
be that if we can show how to optimize
incremental recursive circuits with our
algebraic
approach what kind of streams do we use
time is going to be the natural number
so these are discrete sequence of values
here is one this is a a stream of
integers one think of it from left to
right one negative two two whatever so
what is a function what is a stream a
stream is a function s from natural
numbers to some domain of
values in fact uh the domain of values
that we will be interested then is going
to matter a lot but for the moment a bit
of notation for various reasons we write
s of t for whatever is in the Stream at
time T instead of as a function notation
for example here s of0 is one then you
have -2 S Sub 6
is1 and we are going to denote sorry
we're going to denote the type of
streams for with values in a by S Sub a
now what we will be interested in is
streams in which the values are
Collections and collection
updates so this set of streams that I
just defined is going to be mostly used
when
a forms in order to describe incremental
computation an a billion commutative
group a billion means
commutative so uh this is a general
structure and we'll see that we can get
a lot of mileage out of the
generality and to begin with if the
values form an ailan group the streams
do that too and you can actually lift
these operations plus or minus whatever
uh on streams to make them operations on
streams you do it
pointwise the kind of collections that
we will work
with uh are going to be Z sets and well
of course more specifically Z relations
we're going to Define them later but the
point is they do form a billion groups
because of the integer Z set of integers
Z with these streams we have stream
operators so a stream operator is simply
a function for streams to streams and it
could for example take streams of values
of type A and produce streams of values
of type B why not uh we are going to
take advantage of graphical notation
uh and maybe that's also inspired by
discrete signal
processing uh so this operator here Q it
consumes this stream i0 i1 I2 and
produces this stream
0102 and the point is that the operators
we work with are synchronous in the
following sense at time T the operator
consumes it that is the value of the
input stream at time T and produces the
value at the output stream at time T and
this is important because you can have
multiple inputs you can have operators
with multiple inputs like this one here
and you would like to consume from both
the inputs the values at the same time T
and that's what really synchronization
comes down to what we need to work with
here how do we get such operators well
the simplest way to have operators on
streams is actually to take a function
on values and just lift it so here is f
from A to B that lifts to a function uh
notation up arof or map of f you map it
from streams of a to streams of B so for
example if the input is ABC the outputs
are F of a f of b f of C this uh is
generalized to functions of multiple uh
arguments so here the inputs are a BC
XYZ but the output puts are G of a of x
g of B of Y
Etc what can we do with operators well
the great thing that we always we we
learned for a long time how do we apply
algebra to computer science is we can in
algebra is the easiest way to do what to
do is to com compose so we have operator
composition the result is what we call
an algebraic circuit circuits are
ubiquitous in computer science from the
circuits with bull on the use Boolean
operators on on Boolean values uh to
actually circuits arithmetic circuits in
all kinds of other kind of
circuits so all algebraic Frameworks
defined circuit is here is a quick
example of what I mean ABCDE e are
operators when you have such a uh
circuit it actually graphically is a dag
a directed Bally graph and like every
dag it has sources and it has s let's
asse for Simplicity there's only one
sync it always defines a precisely a
function from the sources all the
sources to the
sync but if you write a function like
this it gets you dizzy it's much better
to look at the circuit itself to
understand how and what it
computes now this has been exploited in
various ways for example parallel
execution kind of lives in this uh in a
natural way in this in this
framework and we are going to exploit it
but in a different
way how are we going to use this
algebraic framework for optimization we
will use circuit equivalents and that's
you know the simplest thing that you can
think of if you compose to operators A
and B you have here the operator B
composed does B that does a and then B
here you have the operator that does B
and then C well these two circuits are
equivalent so this notion of equivalent
very intuitive is used to validate
optimizations in this
platform we come now with the circuits
to the second part of the talk about
recursion we'd like to add recursion in
streaming synchron streaming actually
allows us to add recursions in a very
interesting way how do you do that first
we observe that all the operators of
Interest are what's called causal causal
means that an operator only depends on
the past and the current present input
to compute the current present
output they don't depend on the future
inputs I mean this like so obvious that
you're wondering why did I bother to put
a slide with this right and of course
dbsp uses only cause a
operators but there are also some other
interesting operators which we will
exploit one of them is called
delay it has this notation Z I'm going
to never say minus one but the reason
for this rotation again comes from
discrete signal processing if you know
that that's fine but I'm not going to
use it that motivation what it does
though is very simple to understand it
delays the input by one time unit and
produces the output this way so Z of
some input I at time T is equal to zero
at the first moment and then I of T
minus
one okay
so one thing to insist is while I am
deliberately using the same notation
zero for Simplicity and this zero here
and this zero here are not the same zero
this is zero of the natural numbers it
means the initial time but this zero is
actually some sort of neutral element
about among the values in particular for
collections this is going to be say the
empty collection the empty updates no
updates I'm just going to use zero for
this notation so graphically this is
what Z does it's quite simple and of
course it's causal but it's more than
causal this operator is what we call a
strictly causal operators I might say
for short
strict and what is a strictly causal
operator its output depends only on past
inputs it doesn't depend on the current
input so it doesn't depend on I oft and
of course not on I of t plus one and so
on but it doesn't even depend on I of T
So examples of this delay of this strict
operators are Z minus one or you can
compose Z minus one with itself they all
have this property and you might say
okay okay well what about others I don't
have a simple definition like Z but I
have a way of creating as it were an
infinite supply of strict operators here
it
is if f is strict so it's like Z minus
one and T is causal and T has actually
two
arguments then consider this function
apologies for the Lambda notation know
how to so
T of s you leave s alone but to Alpha
you apply F and now consider the
function that takes Alpha to whatever
this T returns so you apply the strict
operator to Alpha it turns out this
operator is strict strict itself
strictly causal and that for each s so
now I can actually produce a whole bunch
of strict operators you're going to say
why well because that's going to be
crucial for the kind of recursion that
we will do here and so the simplest
recursion scheme is the
following every strict operation every
strict operator F has a unique fix point
that is there's a unique stream Alpha
such that Alpha is equal to F of Alpha
and naturally we are going to call this
fix Alpha do F of Alpha and who is it
it's it's this one it's it's so trivial
that it's annoying at zero it is some
sort of value that F of alpha gives you
at zero which is going to be that zero
that I told you about and at t+ one it's
going to be F of alpha of t+ one but
that has been delayed by one so now I
can actually compute it in terms of
previous
values this is a recurrence well defined
if because f is strict uh it's Unique by
strong
induction uh but note how essential is
the use of synchrony here if this would
not be a synchronous operation then we
wouldn't be able to do
that uh what's what's an example of a
fix Point well the fix point of Z is is
this very
informative I'm being fous very
informative stream of zero so you can
say okay but this is useless what are
you doing here but here is what I'm
doing remember all those other strict
operators that I could do which I
combine an arbitrary causal operator and
I can I already have an F which is
strictly coal and I can combine them and
it turns out that now this has a unique
fix point from the previous
proposition okay this is a picture that
I would like you to keep in mind so all
of a sudden if I am allowed to somehow
go back we call this a the
feedback if I'm allowed to do a feedback
and take the output put it through a
delay operator for example or some other
strict operator and feed it again into a
te then that has again a unique fix
point so you should think of T is the
body of a loop so the kind of recursion
that you see here is more
like a recursion in an imperative
language more like a while
recursion okay and why do I even call it
recursion well let's take a simple
example take F to be Z and now take T to
be the lifted version of a function G
that ignores this first
argument and to the second argument it
applies some function f that's
all now no matter what this stream of s
s
is the result of this circuit is the
stream F of z f square of z f cube of
zero and so on and if you have a way of
sort of collecting all these values then
all of a sudden this looks very familiar
because it looks like what we call a
cleany fix point in various theoretical
corners of of databases and programming
languages right uh so I can in fact
it's already suggesting that I can just
use this kind of construction to
implement data log and something that
I'll explain later is called a while
relational queries that is I can repeat
relational algebra and keep applying
keep
applying
okay the idea actually bears fruit in a
surprisingly General way you can also do
Mutual recursion here is a system of two
equations in which which you have two
operators T1 T2 which are causal and two
which are strict F1 and F2 and you just
feed them across each other the outputs
in as an input to the other one and that
also has a unique fix point in fact you
can see this as a corollary of the
general theorem you saw before but you
need to use here some kind of
construction which I will not explain
but it's fairly intuitive you need the
product of the of the T1 and T2 and the
product of the F1 and F2 F1 F2 T1 T2 and
you also need to swap the two streams
that you
input
now it turns out that this is actually a
a very productive idea in that we can
Define now the general concept of a
recursive dbsp circuit what is it it is
an algebraic circuit that we stand you
know the usual stuff plus I can now and
remember that's a dag plus I can now add
what I we would call feedback
path so feedback also comes from Digital
Signal processing you can get things
called by stable circuits and stuff like
that what is a feedback path a feedback
path consists of two arrows that
sandwich between them a strictly causal
operator so this this is not an edge
this is actually a combination of two
edges with a strictly causal operator
between them but you can actually insert
this between any two nodes of this dag
that you start with so all of a sudden
it soon it's not a dag
anymore okay uh there's an example here
that was the circuit that we had before
AB B CDE and I've
added uh a feedback here and I've added
a feedback there and
the
proposition that you can State here is
that now the circuit with recursion
still defines a unique function from
sources to
sync this is what Dana Scot calls a
proposition that proves itself
so and that already gives us well you
can say oh so that's your programming
language now of course this is not a
practical programming language but it
the way we think about it is as a
compilation Target for a whole bunch of
practical programming
languages
okay so we have recursion now let's
define incremental computation again
with just what we have worked with so
far plus we are going to actually need
to be concrete about the values what the
values are so far the values could be
anything but now I want the values
actually to form an a billian group of Z
sets what is a z set well the idea is to
generalize so this is a normal database
table name and H the idea is to
generalize this and to put on every
Tuple a weight which is an
integer now putting a weight which is
just a natural number is something that
in databases has been experimented with
it's called bag semantics versus set
semantics if you actually put negative
values it turns out that this is just a
right formalism for representing updates
so if a tuple has here negative one that
means that Tuple is
deleted if a tupal has
-2 that means that two copies of that
Tuple are deleted from a bag semantics
table so to be precise a z function is a
z set is a function from some type of
tul to Z the integers that must have
finite support in other words it must be
zero almost everywhere except for
finally many tupal where it can be non
zero we can do with that we can do sets
we can do bags we can do sets of updates
and that's already interesting enough
now because Z is an ailan group then
pointwise the C sets also form an ailan
group and as we commented before they
streams of these sets also form an ailan
group so it's a bilan groups
everywhere because we are in an ailan
group I'm going to also feel free to use
the operations of the ailan group
because I know what they are now again
using uh Digital Signal processing
conventions plus is going to be
represented not as a box but as a circle
and minus also is a circle plus is
binary this is the unary minus from the
AB bilan
group so what can we do with this well
it turns out that we can do
differentiation and integration you
already probably raised an eyebrow where
on the first slide where I described the
word of my the work of my collaborator
previous work it was called differential
data flow and differential data log what
do they
mean well let me give you an idea of
what they mean look at this circuit here
what do we have
here so the input
stream goes both into the plus but it
also goes through a delay into the minus
so that means that well at the beginning
the output of zero is the input at zero
but after that because of the delay the
output is s of T minus s of T minus
one so some people like to call this the
discrete derivative there's actually a
whole bunch of mathematics called
discrete derivation and discrete
integration and so on for us we denote
although it's definable in terms of what
we already have it will be convenient to
have a notation for it we denote it by
Script D and it's a circuit that works
on strings to Strings where a is sumab
bilan group that's what I need and what
it is is that the output is the stream
of changes in the input so if the input
is for example 1 3 2 5 of course I'm not
using streams of integers but this is
just for
illustration then the output is one two
comes from 3 minus one negative 1 comes
from 2 minus 3 three comes from 5 minus
two so this is the stream of changes
that happen in the input
stream dually we have
integration so look at this circuit now
this one is is defined with recursion so
without recursion we couldn't even
Define it in terms of what
exists so it uses the delay as the
feedback in the feedback Edge and it
does here all it does is plus it's kind
of the simplest application of recursion
of that simple recursion scheme and so
what it does let me just cut to the
chase is that at time T the output is
the sum of all the elements in the input
stream from zero to
T and you can call it discrete
integral so if actually s is a stream of
changes then the output is the original
stream so this is the stream of changes
from the previous slide and this is the
original stream from the previous slide
so as probably you have seen already I
and D are inverse to each other that's
going to be one of the essential
equivalences that we use using our
circuit optimization and I and D are
causal I have to keep saying all the
things I Define are causal because I
need causality in order to keep defining
things
further
okay so why is this interesting what do
I do with
differentiation and with integration to
talk about incremental computation in
order to understand that we have to see
the databases as a stream of instances
so an instance of a database is the
content of a database at the fixed
moment in time you can call it a
snapshot a version let's call it an
instance and when you have such a
database of course databases live
permanently to
change uh
transactions I mean not all transactions
but the transactions we have in mind
here do updates they do insertions and
deletions so every transaction when it
commits makes a change to the
database that means that you can think
of a sequence of transactions defining a
stream of
changes so I'm going to use a little bit
overloading this poor Delta also as a
symbol for the stream of changes to the
database to the instances of the
database so the Delta at time T is the
change affected by the transaction at
time T the change to the instance of the
database affected by the
transaction now if I is a stream of
instances or snapshots or
versions then I of T is the instance of
the database at time T that is the
instance of the database after T
transaction have been
executed so you can represent this
visually in a moment so you can think of
I as the integration of the stream of
changes like
this so this is the stream of changes i
z is not delta0 i z is the original
instance of the database then a change
happens that's Delta one it could be an
insertion could be a deletion then more
changes happen and the output is
the stream of database instances as they
evolve Through
Time fuse because they were mentioned at
the beginning are a very useful Concept
in databases a very practical concept
because sometimes certain queries run
faster if you had a certain view of the
database used as if it is already in the
database as is part of the database so
people call these things material
materialized views because they are
being computed and the database
administrator decides to materialize a
certain view the problem with views is
that while they make life easier for
certain classes of queries they also
have to be maintained because the
database changes and when the database
changes you have to correspondingly
change the views and that is what's
called incremental view maintenance so
here's an example of a view here from
that t with age
whatever there is a query every view is
defined by a query so Q of the instance
I at time T is equal to the view at time
T so in terms of streams you can think
of the stream of view snapshots call it
v as the lifting of the query q applied
to the stream of instances call it I
here it is this is the stream of
instances in coming here this is the
Stream of views outgoing there so keep
keeping this picture in mind we can Now
understand incremental view maintenance
as operating as as being affected in a
stream like
fashion so before we look at what's here
let's look at the
picture in the picture we have the
stream of changes that Delta I zero then
the change Delta 1 Delta 2 Delta 3 that
the input of this red dotted box the
output is v0 which is the original view
on the original database and then
changes to that view Delta V1 Delta V2
so these are the updates to the view so
streamwise you would like to map the
stream of changes to the database into a
stream of changes to the
view and it turns out that the this is
in fact uh obtained by doing
integration applying the lifted version
of Q and then doing differentiation I me
it's very easy to see this is exactly
what this
does uh again to relate to the picture
on the
previous uh on the previous page
previous slide notice that What flows
through this arrow is the stream of
instances and What flows through this
Arrow is a string of
use now this we call incremental
computation but that's not how
incremental computation is implemented
obviously it would be pretty stupid to
keep creating all the instances so what
you want to do is whenever you find in
your circuit this sequence of three
operations
integration uh lifted query
differentiation you want to replace the
three of them with one box which we call
Delta up um upar Q Delta that is an
increment version of Q on
streams and you want to replace it with
a customized implementation of that that
in fact has State even if the query
itself doesn't have to have state if you
want to do incremental View maintenance
efficiently you need State people do
things like pre-processing of the
instance and using clever data
structures so that when the updates come
they actually compute the updates to the
output
efficiently okay and then measure
complexity like can you just for example
pre-process the instance in linear time
and can you compute the updates in time
that's constant perhaps or perhaps just
linear in the update of the input and
therefore that's why you need
state so that's the claim that
replacing here this part on the right
hand side D compos with this with this
and implementing this in a clever way
performs efficient incremental
computation of the
view uh you may recall Q Delta which is
the increment version of the query the
relationship between the two is not
visually obvious because they have
different numbers of inputs and so on
but it can be made
precise we are going to go further and
say well why not replace
incrementalization simply means whenever
in your circuit you
have uh this this composition
integration followed by some operator
followed by differentiation replace that
with Q Delta and and Implement Q Delta
in a in a better
way and we can Define this for all
streaming operators not just lifted
queries and the reason we do that is
because this is going to be used in
algebraic manipulations for optimization
again I repeat this is not you don't
Implement Q Delta like this it doesn't
make sense to implement it like this you
just want to implement it in an
optimized fashion and that's where good
algorithmic work is
needed this can be generalized to
multiple inputs this is the
incrementalization with two uh with two
inputs and one output you put the
integration on every
input and
now I'll put this two together the
recursion and the increment
computation uh
to apply this to answer this question
how do we apply these Delta rules to a
recursive circuit a complex dbsp
recursive circuit one of those that I
showed you
earlier well it turns out that it's very
nice because now all of a sudden we can
actually prove in
our literally algebraically prove that
the composition and incrementalization
commute these are called chaining
rules and that incrementalization and
fix Point these are called cycling R uh
rules and this is hard to read but look
at this so if you do
incrementalization but Z to the minus
one Delta at Delta is z to the minus one
so I'm just shov this under the AR the
point of this is that I made a claim at
the beginning the claim was that
recursion and incrementalization
play nicely together I don't know if I
made it in these exact
words and so that means that now just
repeatedly applying these rules we can
incrementalization of data log you might
appreciate this because all kinds of
complications in the interactions
between between incrementalization
and
recursion the second point that I want
to make as an advantage to to advertise
the advantage of this algebraic platform
is for what's called linear queries or
bilinear queries what are these so if
you have types of Z relations A and B if
you have a query that has this property
it's called linear okay that's a
homomorphic with respect to Plus
and there's also something called
bilinearity which just means as usual
linear in each argument separately you
fix an argument it's linear in the other
and why are we interested in this
because it's very common projection
selection group by well-known operations
in databases are linear for those of us
who are fans of nested relations map
flat map nest and Nest also
linear cartisian product join
intersection are bilinear
Airways is also bilinear Union is not
bilinear if you think about it for a
moment but you can see it also as linear
because it works on but you have to see
it as working on pairs of
instances and people have noted what I'm
just telling you here for a good reason
and that's because it simplifies
incrementalization before you protest
although I don't see anybody protesting
I want to point out that this works for
bag semantics and Z set semantics it
does not work for set semantic is not
true for set semantics you need to add
to your circuits a duplicate elimination
operator a more General one because it
also needs to deal with
negative instances with stols which are
have multi negative multiplicity but it
turns out that this distinct operator
duplicate elimination can also be
incrementalization maybe it's not so
algebraically elegant but it can be done
and you can continue to apply
incrementalization even when your
circuits work on
sets you should also observe now that if
a quer q is linear or bilinear then the
corresponding lifted version on streams
is also linear and
bilinear so therefore I want the same
thing that you'll see here for streams
but before I show it for streams let's
observe how nicely linear and bilinear
queries actually work for
incrementalization so this is before
streaming this is the general rule but
you see for linear queries this Q Delta
is just simply Q don't need to do
anything no need for clever
implementations on the other hand for
bilinear and this is really hard to read
it's still simpler than just having to
repeat everything you do not need to
apply the the the operation on on both
instances but you do need to combine uh
the instance of one argument with the
update on the other and so on but this
is well known to people who actually
have devised algorithms for
incrementalization of joints which is a
crucial uh a crucial line of
work I want the same things for stream
operators so we can use it in our
context and for a linear operator this
is now an operator on streams how nice Q
Delta is
q for a bilinear operator we didn't know
what it was but it was our algebraic
approach that allowed us to discover
what it was and we found that it's this
and I I know do not even try to decipher
this but on the next slide I will have a
circuit that does it that will be easier
to read
but I want to point out that we were
able to discover this uh this rather
complicated imple implementation of
incrementalization for bilinear
operators because we were in the right
framework here it is so you can prove in
our framework that the
incrementalization t is actually equal
to this circuit and in this circuit you
have three instances of applying the
binary operator T but if you think about
it it actually does apply only on
updates for each of the arguments or on
instances and updates and as before you
do not actually Implement increment
integration you just write it so that
you can understand what it does what you
do is is you you keep State this is a
stateless circuit but you keep
state
okay I've subre titious added a point
here because I didn't want to end with
that complicated
circuit which is
Pally entitled
remarks so where do we go with that I
already know where Mii Leonid and Frank
go because you know they found that the
companies they're using the ideas which
again come originally from differential
data flow
and where do I go I don't have any
financial interest in their companies I
have only an emotional interest in both
of them that they succeed uh so take
that as you may but I love this this
approach so theoretically I would like
to point out a few things that may guide
us in future work which may also apply
practically
well typically query languages in
databases are much touted to be
declarative oh yeah database is very
nice because you can use declarative
programming which is intended to mean
you can say what you want the answer to
be rather than saying how you want the
answer to be
computed okay and of course that's the
purpose of something like logic logical
statements
right well the thing is stream recursion
this looping that's not so declarative I
think you will agree with
that
but even with this bit of not
declaratives I think that this platform
allows you to mix declarative aspects
with non declarative aspects in an
appealing
way uh things that happen are
interestingly so you can Implement data
log in this framework and you know we
certainly did um the computation for a
data log straightforward implementation
is what the in data log uh theory is
called naive evaluation it's a
computation of the bottom up fix
point but if you take the
incrementalization that's the semi naive
evaluation okay now those of you who are
not into databases are are are making an
effort not to laugh what's with a naive
and semi naive it's not these are not
terms that I have invented but they are
established so I mean frankly nothing is
naive here but the naive evaluation just
computes the bo the the fix point just
by adding facts the semi naive
evaluation is trying to compute it more
efficiently by uh do not adding certain
facts again and again and
again okay that's
good the other thing that has been a
problem is combining negation with
recursion wellknown problem semantic
problem very all kinds of
interesting uh theories have been
developed just to to to make negation
negation and recursion uh as I say play
nice with each other I don't think they
they we've managed they don't play nice
with each other
well the thing is that something like
collection difference I can add that
oper in fact I've already added it I
said every relational algebra operator
is in that is in
dbsp collection difference and stream
recursion it's not a problem you know
it's just
looping but the way I suggest that we
think about it is the following look at
this this is a construct that in the
style of procedural languages that does
the the
following you keep applying relational
algebra expressions to some relation
variables and then you assign the
results to those relation variables and
you keep doing that while the content of
these relation variables
change you are going to laugh but this
was proposed I think in 1982 by Chandra
and Harel or
1980 and it's such an obvious thing but
it's boy not declarative right so it has
to my knowledge it has not been used as
a practical database language but in
this framework that I just described
it's a very natural application of
recursion moreover the calculations here
they stay in PE space because you know
you just can't go beyond polinomial
space what you what may happen of course
every time you have a while is it may
not
terminate okay so why so so maybe one
lesson is let's try this let's try while
languages for for
um
database the relation algebra is is
perfectly think you can think of it as
declarative it's equivalent to First of
the logic which is declarative
so the context in which I make this
proposal is a very beautiful context is
a part of database Theory which I love
um these are the names of the people who
have made the contributions I'm going to
list here the first one is foron coles's
contribution who showed that stratifi
data log is actually strictly strictly
included in various ways of mixing data
log with
negation I'm not going to be specific
which one you Pro but various ways uh
which is a which actually is a result
that is underappreciated by the
community at large I've talken I've
talked to systems people who only
understand adding negation to recursion
as using stratifi data LW and I don't
think they know this result I mean
certainly they knew after I told them
but other things are some monsters
called data log negation negation this
one you put negation in the rules but
you also put negation on the heads of
the rules I'm not going to try to Define
it it's equivalent to First of the logic
plus some fix points but those fix
points can be defined equivalently in
inflationary semantics inflationary
semantics is perfectly uh perfectly well
working with this kind of recursion I've
showed you but it's a equivalent in
expressive power with monotone and
positive fix point and so on these are
called fixo queries then there are these
things called the while queries these
ones you can Define them using data log
with negation in the rules bodies but
you only take partial piix point because
sometimes it doesn't
terminate or you do uh first of the
logic with partial fix point or you do
this wild that I just told you about
they're all
equivalent and beautifully beautifully
beautifully it was shown that fix Point
actually captures exact polinomial time
queries all polinomial time queries on
ordered
databases while captures exactly all
polinomial space queries on ordered
databases and moreover even on unordered
databases fix point is equal to while if
and only if P time equal p space I call
these kind of results results that
circumscribe our research because we
know it's like we are in a box where we
know where the edges are and it's always
useful to keep them in mind and think
this
way uh so this these last ones are by
vman
abano abano this is vardi vard
andman Chandra harell some equivalences
year and that's
[Applause]
it
I was um surprised that there were no
questions during my
talk usually you guys are a lot more
aggressive but but I understand that
theoretically
speaking all those propositions they
were
self-proving I
think um so if you can go back to the
slide
where are you
going one thing
that is that when we talk about data log
usually we have we think about set
semantics data log with back semantics
is is main not terminates your whole
framework was about
um Z set Z relation maxims how do you
reconcile this
so the implementation of
dbsp uh implements both set semantics
and back
semantics um to my and data log to my
knowledge it does not Implement wild
queries in spite of my
exhortations
um what is there to reconcile so
so non-termination is a fact of life for
systems
people but it is not a fact of life for
theoreticians who always like the idea
that everything terminates and
preferably in polinomial
time uh so from a practical perspective
I don't think there's much to
reconcile from a theoretical perspective
I think that there are interesting a
whole bunch of interesting questions
about the complexity of incremental
incrementalization or incremental
evaluations of queries which are even a
little more complicated than the classes
of queries for which this was done
successfully which have mostly focused
on um conjunctive queries those are
quite simple compared to some of the
queries that I have thrown at you here
so yes there's a whole bunch of results
there and it's possible I think that uh
we might be able to
use uh this kind of representation in
circuits as a way of understanding the
incrementalization of more complicated
ways not
done but this is a
[Music]
provided
yeah you have a
follow no no no
no well just a comment the qu you said
it is procedural and it is but as you
said in the next slide it's also partial
fix Point logic which is declarative yes
so in some sense it is
declarative I mean so so partial fix
point is a fix point the fix Point part
is declarative I don't know if the
partial part is declarative because I
don't think one understands
non-termination and in a declarative the
system of recursive
equations so every optimization that can
be done at the system of recursive
equations that's beautiful that is
declarative now I have another kind of
broader question you spent I don't know
15 years advocating for the importance
of
sem and here I am with a billion
groups you throw out all by putting the
billian groups which again you can
handle I understand you can handle
updates and you
need integration differentiation yes but
what happened to all these beautiful
semi rings that are so important in
provenance your polinomial semi ring
uh I mean
so okay nothing prevents us from
considering trying to consider
provenance even for this language I mean
just the fact that we have a notion of
looping considering and the provence
that we would consider would be what do
you do with the relations over the semi
Rings which are not Rings they I mean
the updates are naturally I mean when
you you cannot talk about
deletion without this now as you also
might know Eric R and I have done some
work where we actually talk about
deletion and insertion in a dual way and
from a provenance perspective you can
represent this with different kind of
abstract tokens negative and positive
yes it's possible that we can marry the
two
um and it's one of the things I think I
would like to do but I don't see an
immediate uh
connection um so associating so so just
like we have systems of equations in
which we will have
updates when when you do partial fix
point you also like in data log negation
negation you also have some kind of in
those systems of equations you have some
kind of subtraction as well well so
um I think that that's also
approachable I haven't done it I don't
know how it
works what is the meaning of par
respond uh it just means that you do the
fix point and if you terminate
congratulations and if you don't
terminate default value either you is a
fix point you stop or you default value
but you detect this is p space I see
so this is not partial fix Point unless
this one is equ the while is the
simplest the while is is for computer
scientists I suppose the simplest way of
understanding the other ones which are
equivalent here uh so while is
equivalent with let's say first of the
logic plus partial fix point so here you
what do I mean that you just add lfp and
gfp for example to First the LC right
but the semantics of it uh is not
neither monotone nor
inflationary uh it is what it is you
keep iterating and if that predicate
does not
terminate um you don't have a meaning
for that syntax you allow it's yeah it's
it's syntax that's right
yes
uh so does your framework provide any
guidance or suggestions about the
efficient implementation of
instrumentalized components yeah so some
of those are some very clever
algorithmic
ideas involving for example transforming
the instance or using the instance to
create some data structures in which you
can represent the updates in an
efficient way and so on uh but if you
look at the class of queries for which
those proposals work it's still a
limited class of queries and of course
people would like to apply it to more
General
queries uh for example data I mean or
even you know recursion of conjunctive
queries or something like that and we
don't quite know how to do that but
maybe this can
help stain is going to work on that
right